dance pop de bolton des scènes de retour
à la normale il souvenir du confinement
sont encore présents dans la mémoire de
certains clients
un moment on se faisait dire qu'on ne
pouvait rencontrer qu'une seule personne
à l'extérieur se souvient cette
électrice conservatrice elle ne cache
donc pas sa déception d'avoir appris que
pendant ce temps des rassemblements
arrosé ont été organisée à la résidence
du premier ministre
si elle a pu malgré tout boris johnson
d'autres électeurs de la petite ville du
nord de l'angleterre sont moins
indulgents
les gens ont perdu confiance dit cet
homme certains demandent même au député
conservateur local de forcer la tenue
d'un vote de confiance
mettez quelqu'un d'autre à sa place dit
il
lors des dernières élections en 2019 le
candidat conservateur l'avait emporté
avec une avance de moins de 500 voix
mettant fin à un règne de 22 ans du
parti travailliste un scénario semblable
à ce qui s'est produit dans plusieurs
autres circonscriptions de la région
ce coin de l'angleterre est surnommé le
mur rouge pas pour les briques héritée
de la révolution industrielle mais parce
que cette région était un bastion
travailliste mais ici la situation
économique s'est assombri au cours des
dernières décennies une réalité sur
laquelle boris johnson a su capitaliser
vue comme la personne qui a réalisé le
break site en angleterre et donc la glu
président qui arrive avec son lot de
promesses de réguler l'immigration de
d'avoir des politiques économiques
nationaliste en faveur des entreprises
anglaises donc pouvoir potentiellement
préserver des emplois
à l'intérieur dans cette région
l'angleterre qui est encore assez pauvre
en 2019 boris johnson a ainsi permis à
ses troupes de rapporter la plus grande
majorité conservatrice en 30 ans depuis
sa cote de popularité a grandement
baissé ce qui pousse certains nouveaux
élus à prendre leurs distances ils
veulent simplement continuer à être élus
par leurs électeurs mais ils n'ont pas
cette assise qu'on l'ait d'autres
députés conservateurs qui sont là depuis
des années et qui ont
qui ont
fait loyal à boris johnson
issu d'une famille travailliste reach
clift s'était réjouie de la victoire de
boris johnson un élu différents en qui
ils avaient espoir
c'est juste un autre politicien et
constate celle aujourd'hui mais ce
travailleurs du textile favorable aux
grecs si tu n'es pas du tout convaincu
qu'il votera en faveur de l'opposition
travailliste lors du prochain scrutin
prévu en 2024
comme quoi certains débats politiques ne
se limite pas à des personnalités
publiques ici rappelle bouvier auclair
radio-canada à banteux royaume uni